[Applause]
just want to say a couple of words it's
very difficult to sum up how we feel
about this building and all of our fans
but let's not let me just say that for
47 years Warriors fans have stuck with
us through thick and thin
and let's be honest most of those years
have been a little thin but we got some
good stuff going on right now
but I can tell you I can tell you that
from the first day I walked into this
building my first trip as a rookie in
the NBA in 1988 the the atmosphere in
this place just jumped out of the gym
the electricity the field and that hell
dwell there for 15 years as a player
coming in as an opponent coming in as a
broadcaster broadcasting the loudest
game I've ever heard which was game six
if we believe never heard that
and all the way now as a coach the
privilege to walk into this building and
feel that juice feel that energy that
you all bring and that this building has
brought as well all we can say is thank
you to all of you fans
I want to say I want to say a special
thank you to all of our arena employees
here who do an amazing job
and then just you know thinking about
how many generations of Warriors fans
are in the crowd today you know we know
we know that your love for our team is
something that you pass on to the next
generation so I want to thank all of you
who are new warrior fans thank all of
you who've been with us for a long time
and maybe go home and thank your
grandparents or your parents or whoever
turned you on to to the Golden State
Warriors all those years ago thank you
obviously this is the ceremonial final
game at Oracle we've got a few more to
come and we're gonna need we're going to
need every bit of your support these
next couple of months so thank you and
behind me we've got a banner banner
signifying 47 years here at Oracle Arena
and this banner will hang in the new
chase Center as well so thank you to
everybody we love you will see and see
in the playoffs
[Applause]
Joe alaikum and Peter Guber Steph Curry
and Steve Kerr put a bow on it nicely
and this 40 cent
Oakland California banner will be moved
and hang at Chase Center next year now
it's going to hang here all throughout
the playoff run and then go to the new
building at Chase Center to honor the
forty-seven seasons that we saw for your
basketball and the oldest and one of the
greatest NBA arenas we've had the
privilege to watch games in and you
played here Jim yes super podcast for 34
seasons that's a lot of years as you
said before the game I've been here for
all five decades and I hadn't really
thought of that and when you said that I
was a little gulp and probably
swallowing it's a lot to take in and I
know this summer is when I'm going to
reflect on everything and there
everything's written about this we've
talked about it everyone has
participated and in this celebration and
it is very special and the last few
years that young man you just saw has
made it even more special
an area with two football teams and two
baseball teams one basketball team
[Music]
and that's that 47 a nice touch
Peter Guber and Joe alaikum don't miss a
trick Jim that's a wave no take to honor
the Bey's team